one interesting thing to get back to
college campuses is uh the fire keeps
the college free speech ranking yes at
rankings.thefire.org I'm very proud of
them I highly recommend because forget
that even just the ranking you get to
learn a lot about the universities from
this entirely different perspective than
people are used to when they go to pick
whatever University they want to go to
it just gives another perspective on the
whole thing and it gives quotes from
people that are students there and so on
like about their experiences and and it
gives different maybe you could speak to
the various measures here before we talk
about who's in the top five and who's in
the bottom five what what what are the
different uh parameters that contribute
to the evaluation so people have been
asking me since day one to do a ranking
of schools according to freedom of
speech and even though we had we had the
best database in existence of Campus
speech codes
policies that universities have that
violate First Amendment or First
Amendment Norms we also have the best
database of we call the disinvitation
database it's but it's actually the it's
better named the D platforming database
which is what we're going to call it and
these are all cases where somebody was
invited as a speaker to campus and they
were disinvited disinvited or D
platforming also includes shouting down
um so they showed up and they couldn't
really speak yeah exactly
um and and uh and so having that what we
really needed in order to have some
serious social science to really make a
serious argument about what the ranking
was
um was to be able to one get a better
sense of how many professors were
actually getting punished during this
time
um and then the the biggest missing
element was to be able to ask students
directly what the environment was like
on that campus for freedom of speech are
you comfortable disagreeing with each
other are you comfortable disagreeing
with your uh with your professors do you
think violence is acceptable in response
to a speaker do you think shouting uh do
you think shouting down is okay do you
think blocking people's access to a
speaker is okay and once we were able to
get all those elements together we uh
first did a test run I think in 2019
about 50 and we've been doing it for
four years now always trying to make the
methodology more and more precise to
better reflect the actual environment at
particular schools and this year the
number one school was Michigan
Technological University which was a a
nice surprise the number two school was
actually Auburn University
um which was nice to see in the top 10
the most well-known prestigious school
is actually UVA which did really well
this year University of Chicago was not
happy that they weren't number one but
University of Chicago is 13 and they had
been number one or in the top three for
years prior to that really so can you
explain it's almost surprising is it
because of uh like the really strong
economics departments and things like
this or what why they had a case
involving a student they wouldn't
recognize a chapter of Turning Point USA
and they made a very classic argument
that we and classic in the bad way that
we hear campuses across the country oh
we have a campus Republicans so we don't
need this additional conservative group
and we're like no I'm sorry like we've
seen dozens and dozens if not hundreds
of attempts to get this one particular
conservative student uh student Group D
recognized or not recognized and so we
told them like listen this like we told
them at fire that uh you know we
consider this serious and they wouldn't
recognize the group so that that's a
that that's a point down in our ranking
and it was enough to knock them from
they probably would have been number two
in the rankings uh but now they're 13
out of 248 they're still one of the best
schools in the country I have no problem
uh saying that the school that did not
do so well
um at a negative 10.69 negative 10.69
and we rounded up to zero was Harvard
and Harvard has been not very happy with
that result the only school to receive
the abysmal ranking yeah and there are a
couple oh Harvard oh Harvard and there
are a couple people who have actually
been really I think making a mistake by
getting very Harvard
um sounding by being like I've had
statisticians look at this and they they
think your methodology is a joke and uh
and like pointing out and this case
wasn't that important and that scholar
wasn't that scholar like one of the
arguments against one of the scholars
that we counted against them for uh
punishing was that that wasn't a very
you know famous or influential scholar
it kind of like so your argument seems
to be snobbery like essentially that
like you you're not understanding our
methodology for one thing and then
you're saying that actually that scholar
wasn't important enough to count and by
the way Harvard
by the way Harvard
um if we yeah if we even if we took all
of your arguments as true even if we
decided to get rid of those two
professors
um you would still be in negative
numbers you would still be dead last you
would still be after Georgetown and Penn
and neither of those schools are good
for freedom of speech I should say the
the bottom five is the University of
Pennsylvania thank you said Penn uh the
University of South Carolina Georgetown
University and Fordham University all
very well earned that they have so many
bad cases at all of those schools what's
the best way to find yourself in the
bottom five if you're a university
what's what's the fastest way to that
negative to that zero a lot of
de-platforming
um that uh when we looked at the bottom
five uh 81 of attempts to get speakers
de-platformed were successful at the
bottom five um there were a couple
schools I think Penn included where
every single attempt every time a
student like objected a student group
objected to that speaker coming they
canceled this the speech and I think I
think Georgetown was 100 successful I
think Penn had 100 success rate I think
Harvard did stand up for a couple but
mostly uh people got D platform there as
well so how do you push back on
de-platforming well who who would do it
is it other students is it faculty is it
the administration what's the Dynamics
of uh pushing back of basically because
I imagine
some of it is culture but imagine every
university has a bunch of students who
will protest basically every speaker and
it's a question of how you respond to
that protest well here's here's the
dirty little secret about like the big
change in 2014.
um and and fire and me and height um
have been very clear that the big change
that we saw on campus was that for most
of my career students were great
um on freedom of speech they were the
best constituency for free speech
absolutely unambiguously until about
2013 2014. and it was only in 2014 where
we had these very you know kind of sad
for us experience where suddenly
students were the ones advocating for
de-platforming and new speech codes kind
of in a similar way that they had been
doing in say like the mid 80s for
example but here's the Dirty Little
Secret
it's not this it's just the students
it's students and administrators some
sometimes only a handful of them though
working together to make uh to create
some of these problems and this was
exactly what happened at Stanford when
Kyle Duncan uh a fifth Circuit Judge
tried to speak at my alma mater and a
fifth of the class showed up to shout
him down
um it was a real showing of The of what
was what was going on that 10 minutes
into the shout down of a fifth Circuit
Judge and I keep on emphasizing that
because I'm a constitutional lawyer if
it's circular judges are big deals
they're one level below the Supreme
Court
um you know about a fifth of the school
shows up to shut them down
after 10 minutes of shouting him down an
administrator a Dei administrator gets
up with a prepared speech that she that
she's written that's a seven minute long
speech where she talks about uh Free
Speech maybe the juice isn't worth the
squeeze and we we we're at this law
school where people could learn to
challenge these norms so it's clear that
there was coordination you know amongst
some of these administrators and from
talking to students there they were in
meetings extensive meetings for a long
time they show up do a shout down then
they take an additional seven minutes to
to to lecture the speaker on Free Speech
not being not the juice of free speech
not being worth the squeeze
um and then for the rest of it it's just
constant heckling
um after she after she leaves this is
clearly and this and something very
similar you know happened a number of
times at Yale where it was very clearly
administrators were helping along with a
lot of these disruptions so I think
every time there is a shout down at a
university the investigation should be
first and foremost did administrators
help create this problem did they do
anything to stop it because I think a
lot of what's really going on here is
the hyper bureaucratization of
universities with a lot more ideological
people who think of their primary job as
basically like policing speech more or
less they're encouraging students sorry
they're encouraging students who have
opinions they like
um to do shout Downs um and that's why
they really need to investigate this and
it is uh at Stanford the administrator
who who gave the prepared remarks um
about the juice not being worth the
squeeze she has not been invited back to
Stanford but she's one of the only
examples I can think of when these
things happen a lot where an
administrator clearly facilitated
something that was a shout down or
de-platforming or resulted in a
professor getting fired or resulted in a
student getting expelled where the
administrator has got off scot-free or
probably in some cases even gotten a
promotion and so a small number of
Administrators maybe even a single
administrator
could participate in the encouraging and
the organization and thereby and power
the whole process and that's something
I've seen throughout my entire career
and the only thing is kind of hard to
catch this sort of in the act so to
speak and that's one of the reasons why
it's helpful for people to know about
this you know
uh because it was this amazing case this
was at University of Washington
um and we actually featured this in a
documentary he made in 2015 20 that came
out in 2015 2016. called can we take a
joke
um and this was when we started noticing
something was changing on campus we also
heard that comedians were saying that
they couldn't use their Good Humor
anymore this was right around the time
that Jerry Seinfeld and Chris Rock said
that they couldn't uh they didn't want
to play on campuses because they they
could they they couldn't be funny uh but
we featured a case of a comedian who
wanted to do a musical called The
Passion of the musical making fun of The
Passion of the Christ with the stated
goal of offending everyone every group
equally it was very very much a South
Park Mission
um and it's an unusual case because we
actually got documentation of
Administrators buying tickets for angry
students and holding an event where they
where they trained them to to jump up in
the middle of it and Shout I'm a
offended like they they bought them
tickets they sent them to this this
thing with the goal of shouting it down
now unsurprisingly when you send an
angry group of students to shut down a
play it it's not going to end at just
I'm offended
um and it got heated there were death
threats being thrown uh the um the and
then the Pullman Washington police told
uh Chris uh Chris Lee the guy who made
the play that he they wouldn't actually
protect him now it's not every day
you're gonna have that kind of hard
evidence that that that of actually
seeing the administrators be so uh so
Brazen that they recorded the fact that
they bought them tickets and sent them
but I think a lot of that stuff is is
going on and I think it's the it's a
good excuse to cut down on one of the
big problems in higher education today
which is hyper bureaucratization
the new experience is there a
distinction between administrators and
faculty in terms of uh perpetrators of
this of these kinds of things so if if
we got rid of all like Harvey's talked
about uh getting rid of a large
percentage of the administration does
that help fix the problem or is the
faculty also yeah small
percent of the faculty also part of the
encouraging in the organization of these
kind of cancel yeah and and that's
something that has been profoundly
disappointing um is that when you look
at the huge uptick in attempts to get
professors fired that we've seen over
the last 10 years
and actually over the last 22 years as
far back as our records go
um at first they were overwhelmingly led
by administrators attempts to get
professors punished
um and that was most you know I'd say
that was my career up until 2013 was was
fighting back at administrative excesses
um then you start having the problem in
2014 of students trying to get people
canceled um and that really accelerated
in 2017 and the number so one way that
one one thing that makes it easier to
document is are the petitions to get
professors fired or punished and how
disproportionately that those actually
do come from students but another big
uptick has been fellow professors
demanding that their fellow professors
get punished and that to me really sad
it's kind of shameful you you shouldn't
be proud of signing the petition to get
your fellow professor and what's what's
even more more shameful is that we get
store this this is a this has almost
become a cliche within fire when someone
is facing one of these cancellation
campaigns as a professor I would get
letters from some of my friends saying I
am so sorry this has happened to you and
these were the same people who publicly
signed the petition to get them fired
yeah yeah
yeah integrity
Integrity is an important thing in this
world and I think some of it
I'm so surprised people don't stand up
more for this because there's so much
hunger for it and if you have the guts
as a faculty or an administrator to
really stand stand up
uh with eloquence
with rigor with Integrity I feel like
it's impossible for anyone to do
anything because there's such a hunger
it's so refreshing yeah I think
everybody agrees that freedom of speech
is a good thing oh I don't I don't well
okay sorry to say I don't agree the
majority of people even at the
universities that there's a hunger but
it's almost like uh this kind of
nervousness around it because there's a
small number of loud voices yeah they're
doing the shouting so I mean again
that's the where great leadership comes
in and so you know presence of
University should probably be making
clear Declarations of like this is not
this is a place where we value the
freedom of expression when it and this
was oh this all throughout my career
um a president a university president
who puts their foot down early and says
Nope you know we are not entertaining
fire English Professor we are not
expelling the student it ends the issue
often very fast although sometimes and
this is where you can really tell the
administrative involvement students will
do things like take over the president's
office and then that takeover will be
catered by the university people will
point this out sometimes as being kind
of like oh it's clearly like um my
friend Sam Abrams when they tried to get
uh tried to get him fired at uh Sarah
Lawrence College
um and uh that was one of the times that
it was used as kind of like oh this was
hostile to the university because they
the students took over the president's
office and I'm like no they let them
take over the president's office and I
don't know if that was one of the cases
in which the the Takeover was catered
but if there was ever sort of like a
sign that's kind of like yes this isn't
this is actually really quite friendly
well in some sense like protesting and
having really strong opinions even like
ridiculous crazy wild opinions it's a
good thing it's just it shouldn't lead
to actual firing or de-platforming of
people like it's good to protest it's
just not good to for the University to
support that and take action based on it
and this is one of one of those like um
tensions in in first amendment that
actually I think has a pretty easy
release essentially you have app you
absolutely have the right to uh devote
your life to ending freedom of speech
and ridiculing as a concept and and
there are people who who really are can
come off as very contemptible about even
the philosophy of freedom a speech and
we will defend your right to do that we
will also disagree with you and if you
try to get a professor fired we will be
on the other side of that now I think he
had Randy Kennedy Who I Really I love
him I think I think he's a great guy but
he's he criticized us for our
de-platforming database as saying this
is saying that that students can't
protest speakers I'm like okay that's
silly
um we fire as an organization have
defended the right to protest all the
time we are constantly defending the
rights of the rights of protesters not
believing the protesters have the right
to say this would like basically that
would be punishing the speakers we're
not calling for punishing um uh the
protesters but what we are saying is you
can't let the protesters win if they're
demanding someone be fired for their
freedom of speech so the line there is
between protesters protesting in the
University
taking action based on the protest yeah
exactly and of course shout Downs that
that's just mob censorship
um and that's something where the
university the way that the way you
actually you deal with that tension in
First Amendment law is essentially kind
of like the one positive Duty that the
government has the the first the
negative due to the thing that it's not
allowed to do is censor you
um but it's positive duty is that if if
I want to say awful things or for that
matter great things that aren't popular
in a public park
um you can't let the crowd just shout me
down
um you can't allow what's called a
heckler's veto
that's so interesting because I feel
like that comes into play on social
media somehow because you know there's
this whole discussion about censorship
and freedom of speech but to me the the
carrot question is almost more
interesting once the freedom of speech
is established is how do you incentivize
high quality debate and disagreement I'm
thinking a lot about that and that's one
of the things we talk about in
counseling of the American mind is
arguing towards truth and that cancel
culture is cruel it's merciless it's
anti-intellectual but it also will never
get you anywhere near truth and you are
going to waste so much time destroying
your opponents
um in in something that can actually
never get you to True through the
process of course of you never actually
get directly at truth you just chip away
at falsity yeah but everybody having a
megaphone on the internet with anonymity
it seems like
it's better than censorship
but it feels like there's
incentives on top of that you can
construct to
um yeah to incentivize better discourse
yeah it's like to incentivize somebody
who puts a huge amount of effort to make
even the most ridiculous arguments but
basically ones that don't include any of
the things you highlight in terms of all
the rhetorical tricks yeah to shut down
conversations just make really good
Arguments for whatever it doesn't matter
if it's uh communism for fascism
whatever the heck you want to say yeah
but do it with scale with historical
context with uh uh with steel man in the
other side all those kind of elements we
try to make three major points on the
book one is just simply cancel culture
is real it's a it's a historic era and
it's on a historic scale the second one
is you should think of cancel culture as
part of a um rhetorical as a larger lazy
rhetorical uh approach to what what we
refer to as winning arguments without
winning arguments and we mean that in
two senses without having winning
arguments or well have actually having
one arguments and we talk about all the
different what we call rhetorical
fortresses that both the left and the
right have that prevent you from that
allow you to just dismiss the person
or Dodge the argument without actually
ever getting to the substance of the
argument third part is just you know how
do we fix it but the rhetorical Fortress
stuff is actually something I've been
I'm very passionate about because it it
interferes with our ability to get at
truth and it wastes time and and frankly
it also kind of since Castle culture is
part of that rhetorical tactic it can
also ruin lives